monsieur le ministre à mme porte de
versailles les maires sont moroses
dénonçant une absence de visibilité au
plan de la fiscalité locale est encore
abasourdi par le traitement que leur a
réservé le prélèvement à la source
absence de visibilité car si le projet
de loi de finances garantie
techniquement leur enveloppe globale de
leurs dotations il décèle des variations
aux incontrôlée car c'est tout un
système qui prend l'eau avec l'inconnue
des ressources de remplacement de la
taxe d'habitation et le renvoie à une
loi de finances exceptionnel intervenir
en 2019 alors qu'ils remarquent les
réparations d'urgence de la dotation
d'intercommunalité et assistent au jeu
de bonneteau entre les ressources de la
métropole du grand paris et des
établissements musique public la
composant première question monsieur le
ministre et afin de faire cesser cette
incertitude pouvez vous leur dire si le
pdf 10 2010 9 attendu se limitera aux
simples ajustements du remplacement de
la taxe d'habitation ou engagera t-il à
minima les bases d'une véritable réforme
d'ensemble
par ailleurs les maires reste très
attaché au caractère spécifique de leurs
missions auprès de leurs administrés
jusqu alors à ce titre il bénéficiait
d'un régime d'exonération de leurs
indemnités et compensant leur frais
engagés jusqu'à l'équivalent d'un maire
de 2000 habitants et plus le prévenant
les mouvements à la source ramène ce
seuil au niveau du maire de 500
habitants et les assimilent à des
salariés pure et simple
allez-vous les aider en favorisant notre
demande très concrète de leur rendre
justice en rétablissant ce statut
particulier auquel il demeure très
attaché merci chers collègues
ma parole est à nouveau à monsieur marc
fesneau ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement pour 2002 tard merci
monsieur le président j'espère que vous
ne l'exprimé pas comme un regret merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gainey vous avez
raison il ya besoin de clarifications il
ya besoin de clarification en
particulier sur les ressources fiscales
et sur les dotations
le président de la république comme il
l'avait fait l'an dernier et le premier
ministre cet après-midi le fera devant
le congrès des maires va indiquer que
dans le projet de loi de finances qui
sera examiné par les deux assemblées au
printemps prochain c'est bien l'ensemble
de la fiscalité
fiscalité le talent local pardon qui va
être réexaminée évidemment la taxe
d'habitation mais on voit bien que on
est au bout d'un système de fiscalité
locale pour les départements pour les
régions pour les communes et les
intercommunalités avec une vraie
question sur les affaires de péréquation
sur lesquels il faudra aussi travailler
et je vous rappelle que le président de
la république a dit hier qu'il était
ouvert aussi à une réflexion parce que
l'un va un peu avec l'autre et vous le
savez me qui compte monsieur gainey une
réflexion sur la dotation globale de
fonctionnement et c'est donc l'ensemble
de ce dispositif pour aller voir
je vous rappelle aussi qu'il y avait des
choses qui avait été fait reconnaissons
le sur la revalorisation des valeurs
locatives sur les locaux commerciaux
avec des effets qui ont été parfois un
peu contesté ou contestable mais qu'on a
essayé qui ont essayé d'être corrigés et
à leur est la revalorisation des valeurs
locatives qui attend depuis 45 ans c'est
dire si elle attend depuis sans doute
trop longtemps et là aussi nous aurons
sans doute un moment ou un autre
ce chantier à ouvrir même si on sait que
ça va avoir des effets de bascule qui
sont déjà faits compliqué en tout cas le
gouvernement est prêt à ouvrir les
chantiers est regardée avec les élus
locaux la façon dont nous pouvons
sereinement les yeux ouverts faire en
sorte que nous résolvions les problèmes
que nous avons sous les yeux et qui sont
le cumul et nous en sommes tous
collectivement responsables peut-être de
l'absence de lisibilité de global donné
au système puis jour et répondre au
dernier point sur finalement le statut
de l'élu et vous dire qu'il me semble
enfin une partie du statut de l'élu que
vous avez évoqué il me semble que ça
devrait faire partie des travaux que
j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure et bien
vide évidemment cette question là pour
être mise à l'ordre du jour de l'agenda
parce que c'est une question importante
pour les élus locaux je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur charles guené pour une
réplique
monsieur le ministre sur la nature du
nouveau projet de loi je reste inquiet
car la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation correspond à 20 % de la
ressource et le système établi à plus 50
ans ne pourra supporter le cumul des
suppressions et de la taxe
professionnelle et de la taxe
d'habitation et vous êtes là pour
gouverner et vos propositions tarde trop
à cet égard vous ne semblez pas
appréhender totalement le problème des
indemnités le statut de l'élu bien que
bon ou si je vous accorde le bénéfice du
doute et je vous recommande une seconde
lecture plus attentive avant en
attendant nos propositions
merci circle